that memorial service for your mom you
planned it like you were directing a
movie you wanted it to go right for your
mom and it was important to you and the
emcee that night was bob saget and i
didn't know why but it turns out bob
saggett who just passed away he was
close with your mother they worked on
something together and you were quite
fond of him right i mean he was really a
family friend he was such a sweet person
i didn't know him well but uh over the
years uh he would always reach out i
he uh he did a play called hand hand of
god a few years ago on broadway and i
remember he was great in the play and
hanging out with him afterwards he was
and everybody has said it you know these
all these tributes but he was such a
warm person and my mom loved him they
did some lifetime movie or something uh
together and they just had that
connection i think they both had these
sort of you know this sort of like
really wicked kind of sense of humor you
know not afraid to be to go there and be
dirty and she she just really
appreciated him and loved him and he
just always put out such
such positive energy and was really
really funny and uh i felt awful i was
supposed to do his friggin podcast
and i didn't do it like a couple months
before it he was like reaching out and i
was like yeah i'm gonna do it and then
when that like you know the weird things
that come into your head when someone
passes away i was like the first thing i
was like oh [ __ ] i suppose
why didn't i freaking do that i know
that feeling i know that that is the
worst feeling like oh i'm a horrible
person i should have reached out yeah i
was i gotta tell you i i've said
yesterday 30 podcasts now
right
anyone you know